arrivver sur TPMP c'est un peu
impressionnant à double titre d'abord
parce que c'est un exercice que je
connaissais pas puis bien sûr
appréhension d'arriver dans une équipe
qui se connaît depuis plus de 10
ans bonjour je m'appelle Pascal de la
tour du pain je présente PAF tous les
jours du lundi au vendredi sur C8 à
partir de 18h à peu près juste avant
TPMP et et euh je suis aussi sur le
plateau de de TPMP plusieurs fois par
semaine je suis née à Périgueux dans le
périgor d'ordogne département 24 j'ai
grandi là-bas jusqu'au lycée où je suis
parti à Bordeaux et puis après j'ai
voulu faire une école de journalisme mon
papa n'était pas trop trop pour donc du
coup j'ai dû un petit peu batailler avec
lui et si j'avais un conseil à donner à
ceux qui veulent devenir journaliste ou
ceux qui veulent devenir
animateur surtout n'écoutez pas votre
entourage qui va vous dire c'est
difficile c'est un méti extrêmement
difficile les places sont chèes ok c'est
vrai je vais pas vous mentir allez-y
foncez si vous avez vraiment envie bien
sûr vous allez y arriver je suis ensuite
montée à Paris pour faire mon école de
journalisme je faisais beaucoup de
stages déjà l'été en presse écrite j'ai
découvert mon métier grâce à mon stage
de 3e j'ai un énorme coup de cœur Radio
France pgor c'est une semaine dans ma
vie mais qui a tout changé puisque c'est
mon stage de
3e je suis toute petite j'ai 15 ans et
et là c'est le coup de cœur c'est là où
je découvre ma passion coup de foot pour
ce métier et euh ma passion m'a plus
jamais quitté après j'ai pas mal
travaillé en presse écrite l'été euh en
stage sud-ouest j'ai fait aussi du
télépoch tiens euh voilà j'ai fait pas
mal de de de journau comme ça j'ai
commencé par la radio parce que ma
première passion c'était la radio la
télé c'est un peu un accident de
parcours j'ai commencé mon métier avec
des piges à BFM Radio ça s'appelait
comme ça à l'époque ensuite àinv racheté
BFM Radio et c'est devenu ensuite BFM TV
que vous connaissez et j'ai fait mon
parcours là-bas BFM Radio donc après BFM
Business puisqu'il a commencé par une
radio chcho et puis BFM TV c'est aussi
euh les anéas de la vie j'ai ma deuxième
fille euh j'en profite à mon retour de
congé maternité pour faire une formation
télé et il y avait comme professeur
là-bas un homme qui s'appelle qui
s'appelleait Claude sansère puisque
malheureusement il est décédé qui était
grand reporter sur sur France 2 qui me
dit toi la télé faut que T y aillees
j'étais là à bon faut que j'y aille moi
alors que je faisais cette formation
tout simplement parce que la direction
avait annoncé qu'ils allaient
transformer la radio en télé à l'époque
et il donne mon DVD qu' qu'on donnait
avec mes images à BFM TV c'est comme ça
que je commence par faire des des
remplacements les remplacements l'été
les remplacements des gens en vacances
ou des ou des personnalités qui étaient
malades et puis un B jour on me propose
un poste fixe en fait mon premier poste
fixe il est avec Thomas Soto pour être
tout à fait honnête au QG de l'info mais
ça a pas duré longtemps je crois que ça
a duré un mois c'est pour ça que tout à
l'heure je vous en ai pas parlé puisque
très très vite la la direction refait
une sorte de jeu de chaise musicale en
cours de saison et me propose première
édition au coanimation avec Christophe
Dolé et là c'est c'est ça décolle à
partir de ce moment-là avec Christophe
delé 7 ans de matinale j'ai adoré faire
cette émission elle continue encore
aujourd'hui et euh et voilà j'ai fait 7
ans avec christophhe dé on s'est
beaucoup amusé beaucoup d'infos aussi je
suis ensuite parti sur LCI pendant 4 ans
où j'ai présenté la matinale également
je suis revenu sur BFM TV quand ils
m'ont rappelé pour faire la tranche de
la mi-journée de MIDH à 14h et c'est 8
quand Cyril m'appelle et me fait cette
proposition passer de la radio à la télé
est-ce que ça a été
compliqué oui sur la forme parce que il
faut faire attention à son image la télé
c'est de l'image quand on est en radio
on fait pas attention à son image
particulièrement en revanche la la radio
est un atout considérable parce que j'ai
appris à poser ma voix là-bas à être
incisive dans l'écriture pour évidemment
attiser la curiosité des des auditeurs
donc c'est une aide précieuse en télé ma
première émission seule je vais pas
prendre les années de remplacement parce
que ça compte pas mais ma première
émission seule en fait c'est c'est
l'histoire en direct c'était une
émission sur BFM TV qui était géniale
avec carvé gateno qui est était mon
éditorialiste politique et Fabrice
delmeda mon historien en fait on
retraçait l'actualité de la semaine on
la mettait en parallèle avec ce qui
s'était passé sous la 5e République avec
des images d'archives j'ai adoré cette
émission elle a duré je crois une saison
pourquoi elle marchait très bien en
audience mais il y avait deux
contraintes d'abord les images de Lina
étaient très cher donc le partenariat je
crois était arrivé à son terme et
deuxièmement faire une émission un peu
plus froide ce qui s'appelle une
émission magazine sur une chaîne
d'actualité le problème c'est qu'elle
sautait très régulièrement parce que
priorité au direct il y avait des
événements qui se passaient donc
l'émission sautit pour pour faire la
place au au direct voilà mais c'est une
émission qui marchait bien et que j'ai
adoré faire c'est ma première
émission toute seule en fait avec avec
deux éditorialistes un de mes souvenirs
marquants ces dernières années c'est
évidemment l'annonce de la mort de
Johnny alidday j'étais sur LCI à
l'époque puis j'ai basculé sur sur TF1
Jean-Pierre Pern a très très vite repris
la main dans la foulée c'est vrai qu'on
ais dans la nuit le décès de de Johnny
alidday il était 2h du matin il y a une
dépêche de la FP qui tombe Johnny
alidday est décédé il a fallu réveiller
évidemment toute la rédaction toute la
direction bien sûr pour pouvoir prendre
l'antenne un peu plus tôt et couvrir
cette cet événement 2h du matin la
dépêche jeement' souvient comme si
c'était hier quand on a un événement de
cette ampleur la nuit la première chose
à faire c'est d'abord réveiller la
direction qui va prendre les décisions
qui s'impose pour pouvoir mobiliser la
rédaction parce qu'on sait qu'on va
avoir une très très longue journée et là
c'est la prise de antennes et en fait on
lâche plus l'antenne parce que le décès
de Johnny hidday c'était évidemment un
choc pour pour énormément de de français
il fait partie de de notre histoire
Johnny hidday donc la direction en
premier et après on se met en ordre de
mche pour pouvoir faire pour pouvoir
prendre l'antenne le plus rapidement
possible faire venir les équipes
techniques parce que sans les équipes
techniques on fait pas de télé hein donc
c'est c'est un rouage essentiel du bon
fonctionnement et d'une émission et là
en l'occurrence d'une édition spéciale
donc on fait venir les équipes
techniques ôt pour pouvoir prendre
l'antenne le plus tôt possible et
annoncer la nouvelle au français et
recueillir le maximum de de réaction
évidemment j'ai couvert beaucoup
d'événements alors il y a évidemment eu
le le mariage de de Méane Harry mais il
y a aussi eu et là j'étais sur place
beaucoup plus récemment l'enterrement de
la reine ellisabeth i où là je suis
délocalisé à Londres BFM TV monte un
plateau technique et je suis pas la
seule à être délocalisée à Londres he il
y avait plusieurs plusieurs incarnants
qui avaient été délocalisés pour pouvoir
tenir l'antenne et couvrir l'événement
évidemment sur la journée c'est un
événement d'histoire qu'on est était en
train de de partager
euh voilà la reine ellisabeth I qui
avait quasiment 100 ans le reine le plus
long il fallait couvrir cet événement là
c'est 3 à 4 heures de direct on est
dehors et on couvre l'événement on
commente les images et on est au plus
près évidemment du du terrain pour
pouvoir faire partager cet événement
d'histoire aux téléspectateurs ça c'est
l'événement le le plus récent et et le
plus le plus spectaculaire de ces de ces
dernières années parmi les autres
événements marquants il y a aussi la
nuit américaine les élections
américaines les dernières élections
américain qui ont vu donc Joe Biden
arrivver à la tête des des États-Unis là
on a fait avec Julien Arnaud euh je
crois pas loin de 13h de direct sans
pause pub en extérieur de nuit je peux
vous dire que j'ai eu froid heureusement
qu'il y avait les équipes techniques qui
m'apporté des petites chauffrettes à
mettre dans les mains et dans les
chaussures parce qu'il faisait très
froid c'était au mois de novembre il y
avait beaucoup de vent parce qu'on était
en en hauteur moi j'avais un petit
manteau voilà un petit manteau sympa en
laine je raconte même pas j'ai j'ai eu
très froid mais on a tenu en direct je
crois 13h et puis à un moment on se
relayait on se relayait mais 13h de
direct je vous jure c'est énorme voilà
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir donner les
résultats en temps réel puis qu'il y
avait un décalage horaire avec la France
bien sûr donc on a tenu l'antenne et
c'était un grand grand grand moment
qu'on a qu'on a partager un grand moment
d'info et puis un grand moment de de
franche camaraderie parce que il faut se
se soutenir et serrer les cous dans ces
moments-là je n'y étais plus quand le
Capitol a été envahi mais j'ai couvert
quand même l'événement depuis depuis
Paris il y avait les images et puis là
je voyais vraiment quoi en parler parce
que j'y étais quelques jours plusut tôt
alors il faut de très bons invités
d'abord des gens qui s'y connaissent
beaucoup mieux que vous il faut des très
bons invités des témoins qui sont sur le
plateau et il faut aussi une très bonne
équipe de reporters sur le terrain pour
aller non seulement nous rapporter ce
qui se passe hein parce que c'est c'est
gigantesque he c'était c'est le le
l'enterrement de la reine ellisabeth i
c'était Londres qui était à l'arrêt euh
des des centaines de milliers de
personnes qui étaient là pour rendre un
dernier hommage à à la reine ellisabeth
i donc il y a des reporters aussi qui
sont dispersés un peu partout pour
pouvoir raconter ce qu'il voit nous
montrer les images parce que nous on
était on était sur un point fixe un
studio extérieur avait été monté sur un
point fixe donc il faut de très bons
invité très bons reporter et de très
bons techniciens pour que ça fonctionne
alors faire du direct et surtout du
direct en continu ça veut dire que bon
voilà il y a parfois il y a des il y a
des dérapages des situations de fourir
incontrôlable des situations de stress
bien sûr ou de ou de tension quand les
imag arrive pas quand les moyens
techniques plantent que vous êtes obligé
de tenir le le le direct moi il méta il
un alle là c'est du plateau sur une
émission sur BFM TV et je m'en suis
souvenu il y a pas si longtemps que ça
j'étais en train de de parler de la
météo et de et de rigoler on est en
plein attentat en 2015 et en fait
j'avais la photo de salab des slam juste
derrière moi sauf que personne me dit
que j'ai ça derrière moi c'était une
erreur technique he ça arrive à tout le
monde mais ils avaient envoyé les
mauvaises images en régie ça peut
arriver à tout le monde et voilà sauf
que moi j'étais en train de faire tiroli
pimpon sur le CH waa il va faire beau
c'est génial et et c'est l'éclate alors
qu'il y avait sal la blam derrière et
quand il était vraiment dans une
actualité un peu lourde donc des trucs
comme ça euh oui ça arrive des retours
antenne inopportun vous êtes en train de
faire autre chose bien sû des crises de
fourir ou parfois vous savez on a une
oreillette alors je peux vous dire que
parfois quand on a un chef d'édition à
l'époque à BFM TV al chef d'édition je
vous explique c'est la personne qui
c'est votre aiguillur du ciel qui vous
dit il te reste que tant de minutes sur
sur un sujet là il faut passer au
suivant ça existe aussi sur PAF mais
c'est c'est un producteur j'ai j'ai dans
l'oreille aujourd'hui voilà parfois
quand on se connaît très très bien il me
fait des blagues alors je suis en direct
je suis en train de parler de tout à
fait autre chose et parfois ça peut
donner lieu à des sourires ou à des fous
rires et c'est très sympa comment je
suis arrivé sur C8 d'abord j'étais très
bien à BFM TV l'émission fonctionnait
bien on me l'a rallongé d'une heure pour
cette saison cette saison-ci l'émission
aurait fait 3h si j'y étais resté je
crois qu'elle fait 3h d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui j'avais une émission
supplémentaire sur sur BFM Business donc
tout allait très bien jusqu'à ce que
j'ai un coup de fil de de Cyril qui me
fait cette proposition euh il me parle
de PAV bien sûr il me parle de de T PMP
et puis Cyril Anouna faut savoir que
c'est un producteur qui est génial il a
toujours plein d'idées il y a beaucoup
d'énergie on a beaucoup échangé ensemble
au début je dois avouer je vous le dis
hein je suis un peu tombé de ma chaise
quand il m'appelle pour me faire cette
proposition moi journaliste d'info 100 %
info euh à qui on fait cette proposition
ça m'a un peu surpris normal mais je
connais Cyril depuis des années alors on
n'est pas amis mais on s'est toujours
suivi j'étais plusieurs fois allé sur le
plateau de de Touche pas à mon poste il
m'avait invité plusieurs fois euh
évidemment j'ai j'ai j été allé ça
s'était toujours très bien passé cyril a
toujours été très bienveillant à mon
égard et moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié
Cyril moi j'ai suivi évidemment
l'explosion de de sa carrière à distance
donc quand Cyril m'appelle évidemment je
réponds j'adore échanger avec lui faut
savoir que Cyril c'est quelqu'un
d'incroyable alors vous voyez évidemment
le personnage à la télé l'animateur
incroyable qu'il est mais c'est aussi un
producteur euh et un businessman
formidable donc euh donc il me parle de
ça en fait moi c'est ça aussi qui me
convain je vais le voir il me dit est-ce
que tu es prête à venir me voir chez moi
il était dans le sud à ce moment-là
parce qu'on est au mois de juillet moi
je suis fini la saison mais lui est déjà
en vacances euh quand il m'appelle et
euh et je lui dis ok je viens de voir je
suis en aller-retour je viens de voir
chez toi et euh nous avons déjeuné
ensemble j'ai passé la journée avec lui
et ce qui m'a beaucoup euh ce qui ce qui
me fait basculer outre les propositions
qui étaient génial et qui me faisait
évidemment changer de de registre mais
euh j'ai trouvé que Cyril c'est la
vérité moi je le vois au quotidien c'est
c'est un homme des médias qui sait très
très bien à qui il parle qui sa qui a
une analyse qui moi a fait écho chez moi
une analyse percutante du paysage
audiovisuel français aujourd'hui qui a
surtout une vision et je c'est ça qui me
fait basculer je me dis voilà c'est
génial le monde change j'y vais j'y vais
voilà je change de je change de
crèmeerie alors c'est sûr que ça a été
voilà une décision importante à prendre
parce que je fais plus exactement la
même chose aujourd'hui II je traite
d'une je traite plus d'info pure et et
et dur comme je le faisais avant mais je
traite de l'information autrement et et
j'en suis très heureuse passer d'une
chaîne d'info en continue à une chaîne
généraliste ça paraît sur le
papier un grand saut vers l'inconnu
maintenant les bases que j'ai
acquis avec la chaîne info me sert tous
les jours je vous le dis franchement
l'avantage sur C H8 c'est que je peux
être beaucoup plus décontracté je
l'étais sur BFM TV mais il fallait quand
même voilà rester sérieux souv parce que
je traite d'informations difficile là
évidemment le ton est beaucoup plus
léger et je prends beaucoup beaucoup de
plaisir après les bases que j'ai
évidemment les bases infos que j'ai je
les a ça coule dans mon sang c'est mon
ADN donc ça ça ça changera jamais et ça
m'aide pour la construction des des
émissions ça me m'aide aussi sur tes PMP
ça me permet d'apporter de la matière la
matière info supplémentaire à à TPMP ou
à poser des questions aux invités quand
quand c'est possible là mon métier
évidemment me sert énormément j'adore
faire cette émission PAF et je m'amuse
aussi beaucoup sur le plateau TPMP là je
découvre un nouvel exercice qui n'est
pas du tout le mien l' exercice que que
j'ai jamais pratiqué mais ça m'amuse
beaucoup pour l'instant je prends mes
marques faut être sympa avec
moi arrivver sur tes PMP c'est un peu
impressionnant à double titre d'abord
parce que c'est un exercice que je
connaissais pas donc appréhension
évidemment sur sur les débats les prises
de parole et puis bien sûr appréhension
d'arriver dans une équipe qui se connaît
depuis plus de 10 ans moi je suis la
petite nouvelle çaz c'est comme quand
dans votre famille il y a votre frère
qui vous ramène sa fiancée bon on va la
fiancée on la regarde d'abord au début
la fiancée sait pas trop où se mettre
quels sont les codes euh voilà c'est un
peu la même histoire c'estàd j'arrive
dans une famille euh que je connais pas
il me connaissent pas non plus mais en
tout cas je peux vous dire une chose
c'est qu'ils ont été tous très
accueillants et franchement ça fait
plaisir je vous jure vu de l'extérieur
tes PMP ça fait ça peut faire peur vu de
l'intérieur c'est une famille qui qui
s'amuse et qui s'entraide et et c'est
vraiment sympa alors ce qu'on peut me
souhaiter pour cette saison c'est voilà
qu'on s'amuse sur sur PAF que vous qui
qui regardez PAF ben vous appreniez
plein de choses euh voilà s'amuser
surtout je crois que c'est très
important parce que si on s'amuse en
plateau voilà on s'amuse aussi derrière
l'écran moi c'est tout ce qui m'importe
en fait c'est ce que vous qui regardez
euh et bien vous preneiez du plaisir à
regarder cette émission ça je crois que
c'est le plus
important